[Music]
on this monday night meet the newest
nobel prize winner from canada
how this economist pioneering research
had a real world impact for everyday
workers and challenged views on the
labor force quite a few economists were
quite skeptical of our results
vaccine mandates and staff shortages
over five percent
of the workforce is not vaccinated
that's pretty outrageous as deadlines
approach for healthcare workers to get
their shots
and hesitancy on the front line their
entire groups of employees and are
willing to be fired and laid off rather
than get vaccinated the vaccine pushback
from police officers and firefighters in
the u.s plus all aboard
the model train mission to keep a
beloved hobby and its history alive
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin this thanksgiving monday
with some remarkable recognition for a
canadian economist
david carrad a u.s based professor who
was born in guelph ontario has won the
nobel prize for economics for his
groundbreaking research on minimum wage
card's wife captured the moment after he
learned the news he was just about to go
to bed after a long flight he says he
initially thought it might be a prank by
a friend
card shared this year's nobel with two
other us-based economists according to
the royal swedish academy of sciences
together their research completely
reshaped empirical work in the economic
sciences
mike derolay has tonight's top story on
the trail blazing work that earned card
the prize
why bar a
versus why barbie
david card has spent a lifetime studying
numbers but it was his refusal to accept
conventional wisdom in the world of
economics that led to this early morning
call i speak with david card please
speaking the guelph ontario born card
learned he was being awarded the nobel
prize in economics for research done
30 years ago but that's economics he
says ideas take a while to percolate and
garner attention van gogh never sold any
paintings in his life so you know
you want to take that as a
as a
possible uh you know
way to think about your own work his
argument challenged the conventional
wisdom that raising minimum wage would
lead to fewer jobs i think at the time
the conclusions were somewhat
controversial
quite a few economists were
quite skeptical of our results
at the time new jersey was raising its
minimum wage while neighboring
pennsylvania was not so he compared fast
food workers in both states he
discovered that not only did restaurants
not cut back on their workforce they
hired more people because of the higher
wages you know fundamentally if minimum
wages go up even if there's no
employment effect
it's still the case that employers have
lower profits
and so employers may say well we need
our profits
so
uh you know there's fundamental
trade-off between workers wages and
employers profits as an economist he
says it's not for him to decide which is
better he's all about the numbers which
he delivers in such a way that students
at uc berkeley awarded him the best
advisor award 6 out of 10 years they
decided to adopt a no repeat rule
to allow
some other faculty a chance to win the
award but it is now common knowledge in
the department that dave is essentially
permanently recognized for this award
another perk with winning the nobel
prize a highly coveted parking spot on
campus at berkeley but isn't it
appropriate that card the economist who
goes against the grain
rides a bike
microwave global news toronto
now to covet 19 and news about a
potentially groundbreaking treatment for
the virus american drug maker merck has
applied for emergency u.s authorization
for what could be the first pill to
treat covid the drug called malnupiravir
is meant to be taken at home twice a day
it's designed to target the virus and
stop it from replicating last week the
company said a late stage trial showed
the pill reduced the risk of
hospitalization or death in unvaccinated
at-risk adults with mild to moderate
cases by about 50 percent their
application in the u.s is for those
adults who are at high risk of becoming
severely ill the u.s food and drug
administration will review the data
before making a decision on
authorization health canada is also
reviewing the findings
the world health organization is now in
support of additional covert vaccine
doses for immunocompromised people the
agency says it now recommends the extra
dose for certain people because of the
higher risk of breakthrough infections
in canada third doses have been
recommended for some immunocompromised
people as well as residents of long-term
care facilities
deadlines for health workers to be fully
vaccinated against covet 19 are quickly
approaching in some canadian provinces
now despite the mandate there are still
unvaccinated holdouts in hospitals and
in long-term care which means there
could be suspensions layoffs and as a
result staffing shortages as early as
this week heather urex west explains
thousands of nurses in quebec could be
off the job by the end of the week as
the deadline to be fully vaccinated
against covet 19 quickly approaches we
decide it was the right thing to do to
suspend the right of practice
of nurses who are not adequately
protected the quebec order of nurses
says members who are not fully
vaccinated will have their permits to
practice suspended on friday the
deadline set by quebec's provincial
government the move is expected to
impact at least four thousand of the
eighty thousand nurses practicing in
quebec that's over five percent
of the workforce is not vaccinated
that's
pretty outrageous montreal nurse nathan
friedland welcomes the new vaccine
mandate calling it a necessary step in
order to protect patients health where i
work there's a handful i would say a
handful of nurses that aren't vaccinated
i think it's less than five
now are we going to miss those nurses
when they get suspended yes
but
i don't think it will be as bad as
people seem to think it will be but with
the sector already facing staff
shortages the thought of losing any more
frontline workers is a big concern this
is a systemic problem of a long-standing
issue in the entire healthcare sector
it's just really come to a head over the
last 20 months and especially now with
the vaccine in ontario hundreds of
healthcare workers could soon be off the
job too while there is no province-wide
vaccine mandate here many hospitals have
brought in hard-line policies and
long-term care staff have until november
15th to get both shots deadlines are
looming for healthcare workers in the
west as well in bc workers must be
immunized by october 26 while all
alberta health services staff have until
october 31st the vast majority
of nurses
are immunized and they absolutely
understand and see that
the vaccine is safe and effective
alberta's health care workers have until
saturday to submit proof of vaccination
ahs says if the policy results in staff
shortages there are contingency plans in
place heather urex west global news
as vaccine mandates become more
commonplace a surprising pocket of
resistance has emerged among first
responders
in the u.s unions representing police
and firefighters have grown increasingly
vocal in their opposition
jackson prosko reports on what happens
when the business of saving lives comes
up against a push to take a life-saving
vaccine
on the front lines every day of the
pandemic police and firefighters never
had a choice to stay home
some have paid for that with their lives
he was a police officer for over 30
years 59 year old police officer
christopher cockburn died in september
one month after being diagnosed with
covid19 i'm missing a lot in the united
states covid is now the leading cause of
death for police officers more than 700
have died since march of 2020 yet
there's still a reluctance amongst many
to get vaccinated some american cities
report an acceptance rate of less than
50 percent amongst their officers we
have members just like the cross section
of the population of the united states
that
that do not want to be vaccinated
reluctance has now run up against
vaccine mandates as many as 50
firefighters in spokane washington say
they are willing to risk losing their
jobs to avoid the jab it's really in
conflict with my conscience seattle
police have put all officers on standby
in case of future staffing shortages the
sheriff in los angeles county says he
won't enforce mandates if it means
losing officers there are entire groups
of employees and are willing to be fired
and laid off rather than getting
vaccinated so
i don't want to be in a position to lose
five ten percent of my workforce
overnight the issue is not exclusive to
the u.s
active and retired first responders in
canada have held their own protests
against mandates this one was in toronto
last month in every case the response
from government officials is the same as
employers we have a right to keep
everyone safe
and
we've made very clear we're going to
work with every union on the details
fears of wide scale resignations have so
far not materialized after claims that
dozens of massachusetts state troopers
were ready to quit only one actually
left their job
that hasn't stopped the vocal pushback
from union leaders and front line first
responders who argue those who serve
should not be forced to accept
vaccination
jackson prosko global news washington
now to australia where rising
vaccination rates have led to the return
of some long-awaited freedoms today
after nearly four months of lockdown
sydney and the state of new south wales
began easing restrictions redmond
shannon reports on the changes and the
warnings australia is not yet in the
clear
[Music]
a midnight lineup at the gym as millions
of australians are now able to put the
darkest of winters behind them there's
so much energy so much love to be back
um yeah just nice to feel like you've
got a bit of freedom back again pubs
restaurants and stores in sydney and
across new south wales are back open for
the first time in more than 100 days
it's a massive relief you know to see
the smiles on these guys faces you know
they've kept him in touch with us you
know since we've been closed as well
from now until december businesses can
only admit those who are fully
vaccinated against covert 19. in june an
outbreak of the more transmissible delta
variant effectively ended the state's
zero covet strategy the ensuing lockdown
suppressed the spread but failed to
eliminate the virus we can't stay closed
we can't stay closed we need to learn to
live alongside the virus having 70
percent of adults fully jabbed has now
triggered this reopening 80 percent will
see a further easing of restrictions we
still need to get that double dose
vaccination right up and that first dose
up and the faster we do that the more we
can open up in a safe way when compared
with other western nations australia has
been slow to roll out vaccines
prolonging these tough lockdowns
the measures have been met with some
understandable anger in sydney and in
melbourne residents of those hot spots
still face tough restrictions if they
want to travel to states that have kept
infections closer to zero over in the
west or up in queensland where the
impact of covert has not been the same
but still we need those vaccines to
ensure that when covert inevitably comes
that in those states you'll be able to
continue on as you have the capital
canberra and the hard-hit state of
victoria are set to loosen restrictions
this month and aussies will finally be
able to take foreign trips starting
november redmond shannon global news
london
prime minister justin trudeau has issued
a thanksgiving statement to canadians in
his message he said thanksgiving
provides us with an opportunity to give
thanks to the front-line health care
workers who have gone above and beyond
to provide care and support canadians
throughout this pandemic we also salute
the canadian armed forces and the
canadian red cross for sending resources
and help
to those in the area's hardest hit by
this crisis trudeau also asked people to
follow local public health advice and
get fully vaccinated as soon as possible
a catastrophe averted at a major oil
plant in lebanon
coming up fire erupts at a key fuel
storage facility in a country already
facing devastating gas shortages plus
why british police are dropping an
investigation into prince andrew
firefighters have contained a major fire
at an oil facility in lebanon it broke
out at a plant that stores fuel for the
government and army just days ago two of
lebanon's largest power plants shut down
due to a fuel shortage the cause of the
fire is under investigation no deaths
have been reported
an investigation against prince andrew
has been dropped after a review of
sexual abuse allegations
since august london police have been
looking into the claims of american
virginia dufrey she said she was
trafficked by late convicted sex
offender jeffrey epstein to have sex
with andrew in london in 2001 when she
was 17.
andrew has denied it now no further
action will be taken by british police
on this or claims that epstein's alleged
accomplice galaine maxwell trafficked
groomed and abused girls and women in
the uk
ahead a new transplant policy why some
canadians refusing the vaccine could be
refused a life-saving procedure
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
thousands of canadians are getting a new
life or death reason to get a covid19
vaccine
toronto's university health network is
requiring all organ transplant patients
to be fully vaccinated the network says
the decision is based on data that shows
unvaccinated patients face higher risk
of organ rejection as well as death from
kovid 19. now it's a first in canada
policy but is it ethical morgan campbell
explains
i won't live without a transplant
darlene van wyck is suffering from
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and is
one of about 1600 people in ontario
waiting for a life-saving organ canada's
largest transplant hospital has
implemented a policy requiring patients
to be fully vaccinated against covet 19
before they can be eligible for
transplant according to a statement
released by the aj mara transplant
center at the university health network
the team says the policy is needed since
transplant recipients have high health
care needs post-transplant unvaccinated
recipients would also pose a greater
risk of spreading illness to other
immunocompromi patients they may have
contact with in inpatient or ambulatory
care settings the move in ontario has
led to backlash online prompting some to
revoke their donor status calling the
policy
discriminatory similar policies are in
place south of the border vaccination
requirements
work
and there's nothing new about them last
week a colorado woman waiting for a
kidney transplant was bumped from an
organ transplant wait list for not
getting vaccinated i'm being coerced
into
making a decision that
is one i'm not comfortable making right
now in order to live but uhn isn't
wavering in its decision as transplant
programs already follow strict criteria
for example if someone needs a lung
transplant they cannot smoke if they
need a liver they cannot drink it is a
small price to pay for someone like van
wyck you have a good day you're feeling
better you think okay everything's gonna
work out and then you have days where
you're planning your funeral and you're
thinking
you know you may not get that transplant
time uhn says exceptions to the policy
may apply for those with medical reasons
or in cases of an urgent need for a
transplant
morgan campbell global news toronto
chugging on nearly a century on up next
a club's hopes to keep its legacy on the
rails
whether on foot or wheels competitors
were back on track as the boston
marathon finally resumed after a
30-month hiatus the world famous race
had been put on hold by the pandemic
coveted measures were still in place
racers had to be vaccinated or show a
negative test and bystanders were asked
not to offer any kisses for good luck
it seems everybody has a hobby these
days whether it's honing a valuable
skill or just passing the time
but not everyone thinks of leaving a
lasting legacy with it that's certainly
the case for the burnaby central
railways engineers in bc who have kept
their model trains chugging for nearly a
hundred years as global bc's jay durant
found out the club is working hard to
recruit new members to keep its future
on track
[Music]
it is one of the oldest most successful
miniature railway clubs in the world its
origins date back to 1929
and volunteers have now been running
trains for the public since the mid 70s
lawyers architects teachers engineers
all drawn by the social aspect of the
club and to satisfy their mechanical
itch by building and fixing trains
we have three generations of our family
here at the park myself
our son
and our grandchildren now but they've
been on a recruiting mission in recent
years trying to attract new members it
hasn't been easy but they do have some
fresh faces learning from the veterans i
was at a train expo while back at p e
and then joe came by i was like oh we
want some uh young blood and young
members to help
bring down the average age there's a lot
of history for them to absorb the club
needed more room to stretch its tracks
so in the early 90s it moved to its
current location at confederation park
in burnaby construction coincided with
the digging of the cassier tunnel a
short distance away and all that earth
was put to good use we got all the fill
from there built it up and they did a
really good job of doing a very
big track layout to fit into the little
space that we have here
now they're working to keep the history
alive mentoring the new club members
a lot of people with a lot of skills
fixing our steam engines we repair them
on site for the most part and we need to
pass that on to generations at skill
because it's going to be lost otherwise
right in there and they're picking it up
quickly training for what it takes to
keep these engines rolling do it on the
flat surfaces down here
i'm learning new skills like wiring
mechanics
metal work would work
the future still looks good for a club
approaching its centennial anniversary
there's a big age gap out here but the
new recruits are very enthusiastic and
eager to learn from the senior members
they just have to put up with all the
dad jokes what's the worst one you've
heard
um
[Music]
i cannot think i've heard so many bad
ones here
jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
monday i'm farah nasser and tonight's
your canada is the stunning fall colors
in montreal quebec thank you for
watching and have a happy thanksgiving
donna friesen is back at the anchor desk
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other
[Music]
you